wie bewerten sie die jetzt wohl
gemeldete impfstoff zulassung durch die
emea zum 23 dezember und inwiefern ist
es für sie wichtig mit jedem tag früher
der impfstoff zulassung mögliche
todesfälle vermeiden
das ist eine gute nachricht dass eine
zulassung am 23 12
mit stand heute also wenn die daten ja
jetzt weiter bearbeitet werden
das auch hergeben aber man darf die miss
tisch sein eine zulassung am 23 12
erfolgen kann das ist eine gute
nachricht für die ganze europäische
union weil wir natürlich sehr zügig
anschließend gemeinsam mit dem
unternehmen in die verteilung kommen
innerhalb der europäischen union ich
sage noch einmal einer der gründe warum
wir das zusammen gemacht haben war auch
dass alle 27 mitgliedsstaaten
gleichzeitig jetzt nicht auf die stunde
genau aber doch eben jetzt dann nach der
zulassung beginnen können zu impfen und
ich werde mir sehr sicher deutschland
frankreich italien niederlande die etwas
vielleicht wohlhabenderen staaten oder
auch die größeren staaten hätten das
auch alleinige konnte frühzeitig aber es
wäre nicht für alle 27 so gewesen das
ist ein solidarisches gemeinsam seien in
dieser situation und wie gesagt wir
haben in den letzten tagen auch mit
unseren nationalen behörde dem
paul-ehrlich-institut und allen
beteiligten bestmöglich unterstützt
werden dass auch in den nächsten tagen
tun jeder tag früher den wir einen
zugelassenen impfstoff haben hilft leid
zu mindern und auch todesfälle zu
vermeiden und gleichzeitig ist es eben
ein hohes gut aus meiner sicht eine
ordentliche zulassung zu erreichen das
wird die erste ordentliche zulassung
eines impfstoffes auf der welt dann sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren